guys guys
donald trump
he just conceded he he finally
conceded donald trump conceded
what a bunch of [ __ ] okay look i i
got this statement
now my screen my screenshot says it's
from cnn so i'm likely to believe this
is fake news first of all
but it says even though i totally
disagree with the outcome of this
election
as do i as do i mr trump as do i
and the facts bear me out oh the facts
are very much overwhelming for me too
i mean i listen to the debate at
congress and uh especially
in regards to pennsylvania so many facts
were were presented
nevertheless there will be an orderly
transition
on january 20th he's agreeing
to a transition of power i have always
said
we would continue our fight to ensure
that only legal votes were counted
that that's what i thought what about
the eleven
000 extra votes you were supposed to get
from georgia
what i heard the call i thought we were
on a path while this represents the end
of the greatest first term in
presidential history
it really does it really does
these last four years especially the
last 365 days
have been the greatest and that incident
at the capitol
just a solid solid solid presidency
it's only the beginning of our fight to
make america great again
wait what it's only the beginning of
fights to make america great why are you
saying it's going to be
2016 was the begin you're making it
sound like you didn't succeed in 2016
to make america great again unless
you're implying that
by agreeing to a transition to a
different
president a different president would be
the beginning
of making america great again is that
what you're implying
god he and he's so good with his words
here you know this
is so bigly with the vocabulary he
usually talks this because
it's clearly not written by an aide and
he's clearly not afraid of
pence invoking the 25th but
damn
but this is from cnn so maybe it's fake
but it's not